let's say your team has just won a World
Cup match unlikely if you're English I
know that let's say your friend you've
just stormed it against the Swiss and
you're feeling patriotic you open up
your phone you go to your Twitter client
it gives you a hundred and forty
characters and the first thing you do is
sweep through the keyboard sweep through
the emoji on your phone until you find
the French flag and then you hit the
button and it promptly gives you a nice
little wavy flag here the other
advantage of the French flag of course
very easy to draw compared the British
won't let me go but as soon as you do
that just one fly this time and your
character count goes down to 138 writer
1 why does that happen
you've only put one flag in there and
there are much more complicated
characters you can put it emojis in
general are really long in terms of
binary representation but they only
count as one character tacky an N one
character tuck in are really complicated
emojis smiley facing one character why
is the flag - well the reason for that
is down to the Unicode consortium
they're the people who decide what goes
into Unicode and they're the reason you
have 250 new emojis just trying but they
didn't want to put flags in Unicode
because flags change really often in the
last decade there have been new
countries added they've been tentative
changed through military coup or
civilian uprising and change their flag
and Unicode does not want to have to
deal with that so instead they created
something called regional indicator
symbols
oh yeah I can totally write on a
whiteboard there we go regional
indicator symbols and what they are of
our characters that are simply A through
Z with dots around nuts the official
representation on what that buttons
doing what that french flag button is
doing is it's not typing in a French
flag its typing in reality behind the
scenes anything that don't have a French
flag will see an F and then our F our so
come to France yet dot F our domain
names that count is what anything that
does not support that French flag sees
the iPhone
supporting Android in most places does
support in modern versions of Windows
that things still support it it takes
those two counts it goes oh you mean the
French flag put some together lies to
you shows you just one character but the
character count doesn't lie because
Twitter sees those as two characters
because well they are counselors to your
rate goes down so there you go two
characters combined to one making the
French flag simple as that
that is why it takes two characters to
do an emoji flag and not one and if that
was vaguely interesting then I've got a
much longer video about what counts the
character in my own language file series
and soon they'll be on that one's from
computer file about emojis in their
history just here in the meantime that's
wise to characters for a fly and that is
something you might not know
this really isn't coming off is it's not
whiteboard packed this is just a wall I
have just drawn the wall